après plus de 15 ans de guerre civile
le liban se reconstruit dans les années
90 le pays panse ses plaies et retrouve
peu à peu une relative stabilité
politique basé sur une répartition
multiconfessionnelle des pouvoirs le
système libanais parvient à faire
coexister pas moins de 18 communautés
religieuses
le hezbollah mouvement islamiste chiite
jouit par ailleurs d'un poids politique
considérable mais la plus lourde crise
économique de l'histoire du pays surgit
conséquences notamment d'une forte
dépendance aux importations et aux
emprunts publics à des taux d'intérêt
élevés les répercussions sont terribles
inflation galopante chômage en forte
hausse retraits bancaires limitées
c'en est trop pour des libanais pris à
la gorge à l'automne 2010 9 le pays du
cèdre voix se déclencher un soulèvement
populaire massif le peuple dénonce
l'incompétence et la corruption du
pouvoir en place et exigent un
changement profond de la société
nous sommes ici pour renverser le
gouvernement et d'irak tous les
gouvernants présent qu'ils doivent
démissionner le peuple arabe manifeste
ne pensez pas qu'il n'a pas changé par
rapport au passé
nous sommes là pour rejeter les
politiques de la banque centrale qui ne
vous venez ici une politique de dettes
d'intérêt élevés qui nous pousse à vous
tous les libanais sont endettés personne
au liban n'a les moyens de vivre dans
une maison ils ont même annulé les prêts
au logement pour les jeunes le 29
octobre 2019
le premier ministre saad hariri annonce
sa démission
testée à alt et je vais remettre ma
démission au président et au peuple
libanais les portefeuilles
gouvernementaux vont et viennent
elle ce qui est important est la dignité
la sécurité du pays
je le dis aussi m'a fait personne n'est
plus grand que son pays
que dieu protège le liban vive le peuple
et le liban est la transition menée par
le nouveau premier ministre hassan diab
est laborieuse l'année 2020 porteuse
d'espoir pour les révolutionnaires
assène finalement un double coup de
massue au pays
la crise du coc vite 19 ne fait qu
empirer une situation déjà
catastrophique
puis le 4 août dernier l'impensable se
produit
une double explosion gigantesque retenti
au port de beyrouth
le liban pleurs au moins 190 victimes et
plonge un peu plus dans la crise